welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the youtuber
that's nothing to look at and this
episode we're breaking down the
Invisible Man normally when we cover
films as part of our insane detailed
series we have to wait months for the
movies home release in order to fully
pick it apart however in light of the
world changing events that are going on
right now
Universal have released the film early
on VOD so we've had a chance to take in
multiple rewatch 'as of it there's a ton
of crazy things in the film and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down some of the best tidbits
and Easter eggs that you may have missed
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check the
movie out yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now make sure you
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
like this every day and please give it a
thumbs up if you enjoy the video without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of the Invisible Man okay
so the invisible man follows Cecilia as
she's haunted by her ex Adrian who's
developed the means to turn invisible it
really is a terrifying film that has
themes of gas lighting stalking and
there's just a lot going on in it that
makes it one of the best Horrors in
recent memory the names of the
characters themselves tie into several
things and show just how deep the
creative team were thinking when
crafting the movie Cecilia is called sea
for short which is ironic because she's
stoked by something throughout the movie
that she's unable to get it si and
Cecilia as a name derives itself from
the male version of Cecil this comes
from the Roman name cassellius which
itself is based on the latin word caucus
which also means blind in addition to
this the Invisible Man
or rather men in the movie are called
Adrian and Tom Griffin in the original
work by HG Wells which the movie is
based upon the invisible man's name is
Griffin so this is a cool nod to show
that they both played a part
Adrian is a controlling man that we
learned throughout the movie is
possessive over his brother and Cecilia
this is exemplified by one of the
opening shots as when we first get a
look at see Adrian is sleeping with his
arm around her I know that's a pretty
normal thing to do unless you like to
spoon your pillow like I do but it
instantly sets up the narrative that no
matter what Adrian will not let
go the house itself is contained within
walls and trying to climb over one of
them when escaping it takes it out of
Cecelia completely she really has to
give it a roll just to scale the wall
yet in contrast Adrian is able to break
through the barriers that she puts in
place with these when escaping the
property she puts a window up as a way
to block Adrian but he smashes through
with his hand to showcase just how much
more powerful he is than her it
constantly hammers home the point that
he will do whatever it takes to get to
Cecilia and it really sets the
groundwork for the film going forward
now one of the big questions around the
movie is did Adrian actually do any of
it we learned in the film that his
brother tom was behind some of the
strange things that happen in the movie
but we never get a clear answer how else
it is possible at Tom could have carried
out all of the attacks it does seem
unlikely due to the little details in
the movie that point to Adrian's
personality Adrian actually possesses
the perfect mind to create an invisible
suit there are several things we learn
about him that showcase exactly why he
would do it firstly cameras a lot of the
time allow you to look at people without
them being able to look at you a genius
possessing a personality disorder that
would involve stalking would likely
become obsessed over this notion and
thus this drive has allowed Adrian to
create the best optics on the planet we
see that he has ties with a company
called XT vis that specializes in
optical security and this is likely how
he made his fortune through creating
devices that can watch people Adrian's
house is filled to the brim with cameras
and though it initially appears that
they are there for security as the movie
goes on it becomes less and less likely
that this is the case other than the dog
Cecilia is the only one that lives there
we learned that she hasn't seen a sister
in a while and Adrian doesn't really
seem like the kind of person that would
let it go out due to her having to jump
over high walls it's likely that these
cameras are there for one reason which
is to watch over her night and day this
obsession with watching people through
cameras likely spurred on his obsession
with cameras this obsession with cameras
are spurred him on to combine his need
to stalk people with the technology that
he'd created and thus he was able to
build a suit that utilized cameras to
allow him to watch people without ever
being seen there's an incredible amount
of subtext going on and a lot of things
that you wouldn't really notice that
truly speak to the psychology of the
character later we see the in
visible man photographing cecilia as she
sleeps and from what we know of adrian
it is likely the character would use
cameras when stalking people tom states
that adrian was manipulative and could
get people to do exactly what he wanted
them to we know this from Cecilia's
experience and now it could have all
been Tom it is more likely that adrian
was actually behind the entire thing I
mean the guy did put his hand through a
car window just to grab her so he
doesn't seem like he has the nicest of
personalities but anyway he's dead I
don't wanted this to go too much
juxtaposing this Cecilia has several
things in the movie that also indicate
her personality firstly she wears a
hoodie that says Cal Poly architecture
and later she's interviewing for an
architecture position architects put up
walls and barriers and are centered
around creating foundations
whereas adrian is obsessed with creating
technology that bypasses these and
allows you to be able to look beyond
them I love in films when the
protagonist and antagonist have clashing
ideologies and this is cemented here
with both of the characters there are
also a lot of things that are set up
that pay off later in the movie there is
of course the repetition of surprise
that gives away the game with Adrian but
there's also several other things that
reappear firstly the background of
Adrian's phone is the same texture as
the suit marking his obsession with it
early on in the film we see Cecilia
using Adrian's technology against him in
order to escape and this would the
matically playing to the movies climax
in which he also uses it against him
upon exiting the property she grabs a
knife on the way out and it is possible
at adrian knew people would investigate
the house upon his death realize a knife
was missing and then tied to the death
of see sister now it is unlikely that
adrian would be able to find this
specific knife weeks later however when
sea is cooking in the film we can see a
knife which flaps about and then
disappears once the back is turned the
knife doesn't make a sound upon falling
thus we can assume that adrian instead
pocketed it the cuckoo-land sparks up
and starts a fire so we know that adrian
was indeed doing this later in the Attic
she comes across Adrian's phone and the
knife wrapped up in an evidence bag she
takes it out and touches it and if a
finger prints weren't already on it then
they will surely be now and therefore
when her sister's throat is cut it can
be pinned on her if she was in the
restaurant when it was cut but didn't
have gloves or
prints on the knife she could have
disputed it however all of this comes
together to tie her to the crime when
escaping the property she passes an arm
for the suit as well as for shadowy
mannequins standing in the background
watching her I have no idea why they're
there it just adds that the voyeurism
aesthetic that is laced throughout the
movie and the idea that a man is always
looking over here Adrian's dog is called
Zeus and it's named after the ancient
Greek father of the gods dog backwards
is God I would stop at a point before I
get anywhere but the gods could watch
over people even though they couldn't
see them and this further adds to the
themes of the film Adrian's home is
located on celestial drive and this
further hammers home the notion of
omnipresence in addition to X TVs Adrian
is also the founder of the company
Cobalt
which you may know from Leigh Whannell
saw the film upgrade in which that too
was a corporation there's another tie to
a film that when L worked on which is
saw as when si steals a car we can see a
spin it round and there's a mural on the
wall of Billy the puppet from the
franchise the movie two references other
instances of the Invisible Man as when
we get a glimpse at sydney's room
there's a drawing on the wall of a man
in an anorak and hat that looks
extremely similar to the original
depiction of the character on top of
this si is awoken in the night by an
anorak on a stand which also resembles
the first onscreen characterization a
man also appears with bandages wrapped
around his face that two bears a lot of
similarities to past versions si finds
refuge with James and during the film he
wears a top with prestige 1949 on which
could be a nod to the Invisible Man
appears a Japanese adaptation of the
story when C is outside Adrian's breath
can clearly be seen but there's another
thing that happens in the film that
shows he will always be with her that is
her pregnancy not only does Adrian
financially dominate si by giving her
money but by getting her pregnant he to
make sure that she's tied to him forever
now when this happened for death now we
don't know but there are several clues
as to when it could have taken place the
film is deliberately ambiguous over this
and there are two possibilities either
she fell pregnant before escaping the
house or this was done whilst she was at
James's both are horrific but there are
a couple of lines in the film that hint
to an action was firstly si says at the
birth control
only lasts so long and that this let her
drive to escape
secondly we do learn that Adrienne knew
C was taking birth control pills and
therefore he could have swapped these
with placebos in the psychiatric
hospital
Cecilia learns that she felt pregnant
within the last month thus this does
mean that she could have been at
Adrian's house during it diazepam plays
a big part throughout the movie and this
smoking gun could showcase that he was
indeed drugging her beforehand like he
does in the film the movie itself is all
about gas lighting and the fact that
Adrienne deliberately wanted a question
when she felt pregnant adds to the
psychological torture that he inflicts
well you can really go either way with
it I think the fact that he knew that
she was taking pills before she escaped
left clues about drugging her and also
wanted a way to tie him to her forever
indicates that she was pregnant before
leaving there's so much going on in it
and it's definitely one of the best
movies of the year so far though with
everything that's going on that's it's
not too difficult right now now what I
love about the film is that the
Invisible Man could be standing watching
any of the characters from the corner of
the room at any time he might even be
standing behind you right now
I hope not though because you should
really be self isolating that bad bad
man now obviously I loved hear your
thoughts on the film and if there's
anything I missed
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of the scariest details
that were hidden in mid Samar which is
going to be linked at the end we go over
some of the faces in the background the
amazing symbolism and things that you
might have missed so it's definitely
worth checking out after this if you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and so thank
you you get access to content early you
want to come chat to us after the show
either follow us at Definition YT or
click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this month
you can when the Star Wars Skywalker
saga box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you sub
with notifications on the more videos
you comment on the more you have a
chance of winning so definitely make
sure you get involved the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of April
and the set will be shipped up from then
to ever gets the prize so best of luck
to everyone
takes part this is a channel for people
who are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]